hey guys hey it's Owen Wilson here man  yeah yeah now I know summer is coming  around the corner which means there's a  lot of graduations happening yeah maybe  you're graduating from college or junior  college or high school or preschool I  don't know maybe there's a rat out there  that's graduating from learning how to  carry its first corn I don't know but  whatever the case is I'm gonna sing you  guys a graduation song yeah yeah Oh  knows how to sing a lot of people say oh  and oh and you should be a singer maybe  I will  yeah so I'd like to sing you guys a  classic graduation song great days time  of your life I hope you enjoy  Wow I sing for my heart